an uncomfortable walkabout for
Australia's Prime Minister feeling the
heat from fire ravaged communities we
get nothing
they are angry and frustrated about the
speed and spread of resources pretty
much driving Scott Morrison out of town
before he left he surveyed the damage
but failed to accept criticism that
Australia should be doing more to reduce
climate changing carbon emissions
Australia was carrying its load carrier
Australia is meeting the challenge
better than most countries because we're
exceeding the targets were set out which
means we're able to you know make the
targets that ensure that we can keep
those climate movements at what has been
set by the international organisations
that declaration will be scoffed up by
environmentalists horrified by the fires
ravaging the country they believe the
government has done as little as
possible on climate change whilst
managing to stay within the boundaries
of the international agreements the big
goal for all of us in 2020 is to work
hard to make sure our governments start
taking effective action to reduce our
emissions and to minimize this impact of
accelerating global warming here in our
air here in our country there are
evacuation orders in place across the
states of New South Wales and Victoria
this is Batemans Bay a four hour drive
south of Sydney thousands are scrambling
to leave holiday resorts all their homes
the defiant
are hunkering down with whatever
supplies they can get
nearby Lake con Jolla at this time of
year should be a place of seasonal
sanctuary right now the only escape from
the flames is where the fire meets the
water Australia loses homes to the
wildfire season every summer but it's
the sense of scale and lack of respite
which is exceptional this year
terrifying images of people running for
their lives will surely energize the
country's climate change movement which
feels largely unheard by an apathetic
government Lisa Holland Sky News